see youtubers is Charlie so Captain
America Civil War Luke Cage all kinds of
Easter eggs for agents of shield careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen episode
10 yet the Hulkbuster giveaway is still
going on all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a Marvel
related comment on this video be sure to
click that Bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything
winners are usually announced at the end
of videos this is all about the Patriots
backstory but there are a whole bunch
Easter eggs for Luke Cage for Captain
America Civil War as well as the Captain
America comics so number 10 the Judas
bullets from Luke Cage so the watchdogs
are trying to assassinate the patriot at
least it seems like that's what they're
trying to doing so they might just be
trying to destabilize shield but it
seems like part of a bigger plan they
were teasing a lot of strings being
pulled from behind the scenes but the
Judas bullets from Luke Cage were
obtained from hammer tech they were
manufactured based on shatori tech that
had been left over so if you don't
remember from the Luke Cage series
Diamondback is a weapons merchant who
gets all his stuff from Justin Hammer
who was locked up in Seagate prison
along with Luke Cage so you have to
imagine the Justin hammers like sitting
in some cell somewhere still earning
billions and billions of dollars even
though he's locked up but they do make a
couple references to the watchdog's
being very well armed using a lot of
leftover Hydra tech so hydras got a lot
of name drops in this episode just
making it seem like whoever's behind the
watchdog is left over from Hydra so
we'll talk about that in a second but
yay for Luke Cage references it's a lot
easier for the TV shows to reference
stuff on the Netflix series that it is
for them to do stuff in the movies with
characters and stuff so this will be fun
when iron fist drops in March but number
9 Daisy in the spotlight and actual
inhuman unlike the Patriot who's getting
a lot of great PR so that whole thing
there is them just trying to ease in
human relations they're slowly pushing
Daisy into the limelight
the producers tease that is totally
possible that she could become the
director of shield if the show gets
another season or two it just depends on
how many seasons it's getting but you
have to remember that Coulson still runs
the show it's just that they need a
public face so I'll explain that Coulson
twist at the end too
but number eight interrogating the
watchdog assassin so you get all kinds
of Hydra name drops she talks about the
fridge the battle for the fridge that
she mentioned was from season 1 episode
18 but the fridge was just one of
shields facilities where it locked up a
lot of super humans so number seven he
name drops probabilities analyzing
probabilities so you're like wait a
minute how many Marvel villains are
really good at analyzing probabilities
Scarlet Witch can change probabilities
but they're basically teasing whoever's
behind the watchdogs here this is like
laying groundwork to make some big
reveal it'll probably be some big
character from the Marvel Universe that
we've seen before that has ties to Hydra
so there are a couple big candidates but
because the Patriot line flows from the
Captain America comics it just sounds
like it's a Captain America character so
that might be Arnim Zola
he might have somehow survived the
destruction in Winter Soldier when they
blew up the facility where his mainframe
was they implied that he died but you
have to remember he has a digital
consciousness so he could have escaped
and in the comics he actually uploads
himself to this crazy body it looks like
this that actually might be where
they're taking the life model decoy
story this season we're like Arnim Zola
puts himself in one of these bodies so
there's just something to think about
for the future you know no idea who the
watchdog leader is but there's some
mysterious benefactor
their ties to Hydra this is all Captain
America stuff so there's just a number
of big candidates Arnim Zola just fits
with that life model decoy stuff but
number six briefcase red shirt that's
who I'm calling this character gets
sucked out the quintet door it was a
great death fairy WTF but you kind of
knew something was happening when he
started talking about things that had
absolutely nothing to do with the tone
of what's the scene demanded it was this
really sad moment they were talking
about an agent that has died and he went
off on this rant about good PR so
anytime a character that never really
gets any lines and you don't even
remember who they are
starts getting a bunch of lines that
have nothing to do with the tone of the
scene you know some big twist is coming
up so boom just get sucked right out the
door plane goes down in number five the
pilot dies
Firefly you know big Joss Whedon Easter
egg dies Firefly wash style with the
tree branch right through them so if you
didn't watch Firefly it's another big
Whedon verse production the pilot alan
tudyk dies just like this so shield is a
Joss Whedon show they reference a lot of
other Joss Whedon stuff but number four
mate
flipping her [ __ ] in the matrix in all
the jokes about who's more hardcore her
or ADA so ADA goes like full Cylons
she's a badass but so is may so they
figure out that the matrix simulations
they gave her is absolutely nothing like
what she really needs in the way they
describe it like the massage the
acupuncture sounds just like Coulson's
implanted memories of Tahiti so Mays
Tahiti is the same as Coulson's Tahiti
and they figure out that that's terrible
for her so they're going to cook up
something really crazy WTF for her which
when they said the dragons weren't
enough made me think of Hydra again
because what's worse than the dragon
mythical creature
it'd be a Hydra in Hydra Captain America
as a patriot just a lot of Easter eggs
on the show come from the Captain
America Universe so number three life
model decoy may is starting to figure
out that she's a life model decoy they
explained it's all subconscious so she's
starting to flip her [ __ ] she notices
the metal endoskeleton so it's like wait
a minute I'm a terminator what the hell
is going on here so that's going to play
out over the next couple of episodes but
number two Patriots backstory revealed
Captain America Civil War Easter eggs
Super Soldier Serum program so they
named dropped the Earth's kind program
which is the name of the scientists to
create a super soldier serum in that
first Captain America movie but then
they say that they actually made their
version of the serum from Daisy's
father's formula Calvin zabo
so there might be some big Hulk out
moment because he said they took most of
the bad stuff out in his version of the
formula which was a little more raw just
made him just absolutely go nuts so
there might be a moment like that from
the patriot down the road but I was kind
of hoping at some point that he would
get to wield Captain America's actual
shield just because it's now in
possession of the US government because
Captain America
isn't using it anymore because he isn't
Captain America at least until infinity
war so we'll see but they do bust out
Coulson's energy Captain America shield
every once in a while they'll pop that
out the Geoffrey Mays version of the
Patriot is actually someone from the
World War 2 era Captain America comics
from way back they just took up the
mantle eventually so he didn't have any
special powers he was just a badass the
other version they combined him with for
the TV show was the Elijah Bradley
Patriot character so there been a couple
people to wear the title of Captain
America they have been a couple people
to wear the title of the Patriot so the
Elijah Bradley Patriot is somebody from
present-day that uses artificial means
to give himself power but he took pills
instead of a serum so that's kind of the
thing they're going with in this so this
version of the character is just a
couple different versions combined but
just to explain the Captain America
Civil War Easter eggs so when he talks
about the big blast in Vienna that was
the blast to kill Black Panthers father
so he was just like a normal SHIELD
agent that was working there
he helped someone by accident they
thought that he was this big hero so he
just rolled with it then Talbot called
because he knew that shield was coming
back they needed somebody in charge that
had powers that was enhanced sort of
like ease PR between Inhumans and normal
people and someone that they could
control so the patriot was following
their orders the whole time but now
number one he's going to stay in charge
Coulson is really taking over though
Nick Fury style from the shadows Nick
Fury is still out there somewhere we
haven't really seen him in a while but
that's mostly because samuel l.jackson
contract is really expensive so he's
still out there somewhere pursuing X
Hydra agents he'll probably show back up
during infinity war but the other big
thing the other number one is Fitz
downloading ADA's mainframe from the one
that revolted so she was actually normal
she was only obeying her programming so
this sounds like it's going to be the
backdoor to Radcliffe taking advantage
of Fitz to get his hands on the dark
hold you know bits trying to do
something good but unwittingly playing
into Radcliffe's plans to get his hands
on the dark hold so you guys can let me
know like what was
favorite moment from the episode what
did you think about all the Easter eggs
for Captain America and who do you think
is the evil head of the watchdogs it's
like secretly controlling things it just
has to be some Captain America character
and feels like they're building towards
some big reveal like oh my god we
haven't seen this person in forever but
big news about the schedule so the
schedule is going to get crazy with
videos next week just because there's so
much stuff that's happening on Tuesday
Wednesday and Thursday so I'm at the
rearrange when videos post so depending
on you know what people think about
shield going forward if people still
really enjoy the videos we'll still keep
making them but if I have to I'll just
post up to Facebook because it is really
fun to pull through all the Easter eggs
just like go through everything and try
to tie it all together so that might
take on some form on my Facebook page if
it needs to there's some schedule
problem what's going to happen is is
this is like the tentative schedule for
next week
now that doesn't include like Monday
Saturday Sunday or like the other days
it's really just Tuesday to Thursday
that's going to be the nightmare for my
schedule so that might change a little
bit I'll just keep people updated as I
post new videos in the next couple of
days and if you didn't see it I did a
video about Marvel's other new TV show
x-men Legion it's a Marvel TV
collaboration that's going to be on
Wednesday nights so it'll be a Thursday
video it's not starting till February
8th but I'll post the link to the
trailer at the end of this I did a video
kind of explaining the series it's going
to be crazy intense that'll be on FX
networks in the United States
it'll be on Fox international channels
if you live outside the United States
everybody will be able to watch it on
the same day but giveaway time
congratulations to this week hope buster
giveaway winner mr. gaming wolf please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details so while announce the winners
the next time I post a shield video or
if that moves to Facebook I'll just
bounce the winner on my Facebook page
don't worry we'll figure it out so next
video will be guardians of the galaxy to
have some new Game of Thrones Season 7
that I want to post and they're probably
going to be some new arrow footage
tomorrow too what you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for new
marvel's defenders which is actually
coming really soon and you can
a cure for that x-men region trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight